first ever Grammys for BTS drink I'm
sure excited yeah how excited are you
guys you know we never imagined that we
could be here it would always say it's a
journey but you know still can't believe
it on this red carpet you most geeking
out over meeting tonight is there anyone
you're trying to meet and collaborate I
want to meet Freddy Scott a good shower
amazing yeah you're incredible you guys
said one of the most dedicated fan bases
in the world hands down I mean as soon
as you lift your finger and perform will
create any kind of Mele they go crazy
I mean how do you think that they feel
about you being at the Grammys here
tonight your fan base um I mean they
made us they gave the wings they give
all the opportunities to us so I'm sure
they'll be proud and they'll be like you
know we've seen all around like they're
here with us so yeah so we're so proud
do you have a message for the Army
tonight I'm your host mine there are the
armies today I love you
you gave ologist May dollars we're so
proud and so grateful thank you you guys
is such an inspiring story I think for a
lot of people who want to kind of make
music and go out there and do it
themselves in particular you know your
label is just launched another brand new
band as well and I wonder what kind of
advice you'd give them having achieved
so much success already and they right
at the start of their journey
um just we still try to stay ourselves
and just you know we could be like proud
a little bit high but we just still try
to keep on what we're doing
like for example we've been stayed up
all night to work for our next level
right before to fly them stayed up all
night so I think being ourselves a way
for waiting for the opportunities and
challenging is now you have the chance
to relax tonight though I mean it's the
Grammys you know what I'm tight on that
only
no no it's grabbing you could have me
nervous what's the first thing you're
gonna do then when you when the show's
over not a bunch of weapons you know we
want to meet our fan army our in via so
we're gonna we're gonna broadcast a live
show and meet our friends and you know
what we're doing how how we fell some
kinds of that thing well good luck guys
good luck tonight thanks for joining us
congratulations
[Music]